find the natural log of 3 using a  calculator round your answer to the  nearest hundredth and just as a reminder  natural log of 3. this is just another  way of saying log  base e of 3 or what power do i have to  raise e e2 to get to 3 and 3 is a little  bit larger than e e is 2.71 and it goes  on and on and on so 3 is a little bit  larger than e so i'm guessing it's going  to be one point something something so  let's look at let's let's get our  calculator out and just calculate it  so natural log that's this button right  over here ln i'm assuming it's maybe  from french log natural or something  like that so natural log  of 3  is that's one point and what they want  us to round to the nearest hundredth so  it's 1.09 but the thousands place is an  eight which is greater than or equal to  five so we want to round up  so we want to round the nine up but that  essentially takes us to ten so 1.10  so this is approximately equal to 1.10  1.10 when we round to the nearest  hundredth